salut j'ai seulement 5 secondes pour
vous rappeler que la dernière de mon
spectacle solidarité après y'en a puis
c'est le 11 décembre au zénith de paris
de lire dans la description nouvelle
vidéo salut la vidéo tant attendue
au mois de décembre dernier le 25 j'ai
publié une vidéo sur comment deviner le
signe astrologique de quelqu'un vidéo la
plus attendue de cette chaîne
ne fallait pas de sortir un 25 décembre
en fait les gens ne regardent pas
youtube et je me suis dit tant mieux je
l'art travaillerai un petit peu
différemment et le jour est enfin venu
dans cette vidéo je vais vous donner
toutes les méthodes que j'emploie pour
trouver le signe astrologique d'une
personne disque les moeurs clémeur
rappelez vous que je ne crois pas en
l'astrologie je n'ai pas cette croyance
là et pourtant on peut trouver le signe
astrologique de quelqu'un d'une manière
rationnelle en fait de plusieurs
manières différentes et c'est stylé
parce que imaginez que vous venez de
rencontrer quelqu'un avec qui vous
entamer une discussion parce que vous
aviez un rendez-vous pour sympathiser et
là vous trouvé son signe astrologique
est-ce que ça fait pas matière à papoter
matière à discuter à engager une
conversation un peu plus longue mais
comment tu as fait écoute je vais
t'expliquer pour un deuil tu sais très
bien ça par exemple encore faut-il avoir
rendez vous avec quelqu'un qui a les
mêmes aspirations de rendez vous que
nous ça il ya une solution qui est très
rapide ça s'appelle froot c'est ça c'est
utile et je vous explique ça tout de
suite c'est le sponsor de cette vidéo si
vous connaissez pas foot je vais vous
raconter tout ça en détail nous suivent
depuis plusieurs contenus merci à eux
pour sa route c'est une application de
rencontre avec un concept très simple
rencontrer des personnes qui ont les
mêmes attentes que vous en gros que vous
recherchez une relation sérieuse ou
juste prendre un verre en toute amitié
ou une relation par sérieuse d'ailleurs
route vous permet de l'indiquer
clairement en choisissant un fruit qui
symbolise chaque volonté il cerise c'est
pour trouver sa moitié un raisin c'est
par exemple pour qu'on a un verre de vin
sans se prendre la grappe il pastèque
pour des câlins récurrents sans pépin et
une pêche pour des envies de nom loïc de
pêcher grâce à ce code et à ses fruits
vous évitez les potentiels déception et
ça c'est très très cool le lien est dans
la description n'hésitez pas à découvrir
même alors cette vidéo elle va reprendre
des parties de la première vidéo que
j'avais tourné sur le sujet que vous
n'avez pas vu on ne voit en mode play
comment on peut déduire le signe
astrologique de quelqu'un déjà il ya un
fondamental très simple c'est la base
c'est que cherchait un signe
astrologique c'est avoir une chance sur
deux d'avoir bon et dans la vidéo on va
créer un tunnel pour passer de une
chance sur douze a quasiment une chance
sur deux on va avoir trois ou quatre
techniques différentes je vous mets un
chapitrage également dans la vidéo comme
ça vous pouvez passer d'une technique à
une autre si vous vous sentez pas à
l'aise avec l'une des techniques il y en
a qui sont très faciles à mettre en
place il y en a qui sont évidemment plus
compliqué et plus on veut toucher à du
vrai mentalisme plus c'est compliqué la
première technique elle permet d'avoir
une chance sur trois c'est pas mal déjà
pour ça il suffit de passer par le
l'élément du cygne en question est ce
que la personne a là un signe de feu dr
de terre ou d'eau pendant que ça c'est
le symbole du feu ça c'est le symbole
l'eau donc le triangle inversé le
symbole d'air est le symbole de terre
qui sont aussi les triangles dans les
deux sens avec un trait soit en eau
sombre l'idée c'est que vous demandez à
quelqu'un vous passez une feuille à
quelqu'un donc voulu faire le petit
schéma et vous le dites moi je vais pas
regarder ce que tu fais et toi tu vas
juste faire en gros calais l'élément de
ton signe astrologique mais comme ça
vers toi donc la personne prend le truc
et elle fait l'élément comme ça
directement vers l est en temps normal
vous avez compris où je veux en venir
c'est que juste en regardant du coin de
l'oeil avec les mouvements de la main
vous savez déjà
quel est le symbole que j'ai fait j'ai
fait le triangle vers le bas c'est le
symbole
de l'eau c'est l'élément eau donc mon
signe est un signe de ce qui est vrai et
comment on fait maintenant qu'on a isolé
que 3 eh bien il ya deux variantes
possibles une qui est plutôt safe et qui
va se passer avec les lettres et un peu
de psychologie et l'autre qui est un peu
plus risqué qui va marcher avec le
regard mais qui est du coup plus
mentalisme on va dire la technique
simple c'est une espèce dans brouille où
vous allez avancée presque lettre par
lettre mais c'est très rapide pour
savoir lequel des trois signes est
concerné là vous savez que j'ai dessiné
a thing d'eau donc ces cancers ou
scorpion ou poisson vous commencez par
dire concentre toi sur les voyelles de
ton signe astrologique
je pense qu'il ya un os dedans si la
personne commence à dire non à cette
phrase là vous reprenez le lit tout sur
elle en disant ah ah ah ah c'est pas un
aussi un as et je pense que tu as toutes
les caractéristiques du cancer et là
effectivement si c'est un signe dos et
qui a pas de au dedans c'est forcément
le cancer si par contre il fait oui il
ya un os dedans vous pouvez dire il ya
aussi un lit un p il ya aussi un n il ya
aussi un c et si ac il dit non vous
pareil vous reprenez le lead en faisant
non enfin cesser le son c'est le sk non
il ya deux aces et on signe ses poissons
et six as et il a toujours continué
d'agresser c'est que ces scorpions c'est
aussi simple que ça si ç'avait été un
signe de terre j'aurais commencé par
dire je pense qu'un i de danse et la
personne dix noms qui me serait rattrapé
et ça voudrait dire en tout cas que ces
taureaux pour le signe de le feu ça peut
être délié lyon au sagittaire vous
commencez pareil je pense qu'il ya
dedans la personne dira oui à tous les
coups je crois aussi qu'il ya eu si la
personne commence à dire non maintenant
ça doit pas être un oeil ou alors au
féminin mais elle sait le lion y a pas
le choix et enfin les signes des rejets
mot balance verso donc là c'est rigolo
parce qu'au début vous êtes sûr d'avoir
un oui un peu partout vous pouvez dire
oui il ya un eig veut dire oui il ya un
e aide pas sûr qu'ils disent oui dit
d'ailleurs en fait c'est sur c'est sûr
qu'ils disent oui pour le e et après
vous dit peut-être rien eu je suis pas
sûr un hub et là vous voyez c'est la
réaction est négative vous savez que
c'est balance avant de passer aux deux
autres techniques qui sont plus mental
''sans des plus intéressantes j'aimerais
apporter votre attention sur deux points
qui sont oubliés parfois le sens de
l'observation suffit sens de
l'observation basique qui fait partie du
col reading c'est à dire vous pouvez
voir directement un bout de tatouage
d'un signe astrologique ça c'est
intéressant ou un mois de naissance
quelque part si vous avez un mois de
naissance vous avez une chance sur deux
de trouver le bon signe d'ailleurs vous
pouvez le trouver avec une phrase
interne négative maintenant comment
faire en mentalisme ouvert alors deux
techniques une qui demande un petit peu
de matériel qui peut vous sauver et une
sans matériel celle avec le matériel
avec inspiré du travail de tommy waters
un mentaliste très célèbre dans notre
milieu et je me suis approprié l'une de
ces techniques pour trouver le signe
astrologique ligne saint servais pas
pour ça je me suis rendu compte qu'on
pouvait vraiment s'en servir pour ça je
vous l'expliqué en détail et si jamais
vous avez la flemme de refaire le
matériel sachez que ce tour entre autres
existent dans ma boutique brainstorm
vous avez le lien dans la description
l'idée c'est que vous ayez un petit
carton dans votre poche mais sinon vous
le faites vous même prenez un bristol un
truc mais en gros vous présenter à une
personne alors vous n'allez pas faire la
séparation 4 comme ça pour de vrai ça
c'est juste pour l'explication on va
dire qu'il ya quatre cadrans dans le
premier vous allez mettre les trois
signes astrologiques qui sont liées à
l'élément feu par exemple la est
l'élément air l'aller 3-2 l'élément eau
et les trois de l'élémentaire et vous
lui dites juste voilà tu va regarder ton
dont le symbole de son signe
astrologique vous faites juste les
symboles évidemment à l'intérieur et tu
vas te concentrer dessus et vous lui
donnez le papier vous lui tendez pas
trop près pas trop loin et votre but et
c'est ça qui avait trouvé 2014 et ça
marche très bien c'est de regarder si
son regard va plutôt là plutôt là plutôt
ici plutôt ici et en fonction vous savez
déjà l'élément du coup et c'est un truc
qu'on pourrait utiliser pour la
technique numéro il n'a d'ailleurs de
faire ça plutôt qu'au tiers destiné à la
personne parce que vous connaissez tout
de suite en fait l'élément dans lequel
le signe astrologique de la personne en
face et pour elle ça a pas vraiment
commencer vous n'avez pas encore
commencé à chercher en fait vous avez
déjà un temps d'avancé puisque vous
connaissez l'élément là vous baissez le
carton il vous allez leur tournée moi
j'en ai préparé un autre mais c'est pas
elle c'est pour les explications que
vous compreniez mieux vous allez dire à
la personne jeu juste je change l'ordre
et je vais voir à quelle vitesse tu
retrouves ton signe pour voir à quel
point d attache et attend si nous pas
hélas voulurent fait de voir un autre
tableau ce sera l'autre côté en fait en
réalité et les signes sont pas mis de la
même manière ils sont pas mis n'importe
comment non plus vous allez voir pareil
vous détectez le sens du regard de la
personne et là en vrai vous savez déjà
calé son signe en gros si la personne
tout à l'heure à l'avait regardé dans
cette partie là je sais que c'est donc
l'un des signes d'eau ok cancer
scorpions ou poisson maintenant quand je
lui refait voir ça je sais qu'elle va
forcément regarder ou ici ou ici ou ici
parce que c'est là où j'ai de dispatcher
les 1 2 3 donc si elle regarde plutôt de
ce côté je sais que ces poissons si elle
regarde plutôt de ce côté je sais que
ces cancers et si elle regarde plutôt de
ce côté je sais que c'est scorpion est
comme ça vous pouvez vous faire ça
chaque dernières techniques les faits
d'ariane migrer c'est clairement le plus
risqué mais en même temps quand il
fonctionne bien c'est le plus beau pour
pouvoir réussir cette technique et je
vous recommande ce à tout faire pour
toutes les techniques il faut évidemment
connaître les signes astrologiques
hockey dans l'orne et moi et c'est donc
le cancer le lion la vierge la balance
le scorpion le sagittaire le capricorne
le verso le poisson et le toro de j'aime
parce que même si vous ne croyez pas en
l'astrologie comme moi si vous voulez
avoir la prétention d'essayer de deviner
racing vous devez vous intéressé à ça
vous pouvez ensuite utiliser dans votre
tête la technique du palais mental pour
retenir un maximum de clichés des
clichés qui sont véhiculées par les
livres d'astrologie sur ces signaux là
alors attention j'en entends qui vont
dire oui mais attends tu parles des
signes solaire on parle pas des
ascendants on parle pas des signes
lunaire non je ne crois par l'astrologie
encore une fois c'est fait pour des
effets bluffant sur quelque chose ou à
la base on a une chance sur 12 de
trouver encore une fois je ne me targue
pas d'être un astrologue et de maîtriser
le sujet mieux que ceux qui croient en
tout cas voici comment vous allez faire
la première étape il ya que deux étapes
la première c'est d'apprendre par coeur
toutes les caractéristiques de tous les
cygnes alors vraiment les
caractéristiques basiques que je vous
recommande de faire c'est les défauts
des personnes et les qualités des
personnes basta tout le reste tout le
blabla on s'en fiche ensuite la deuxième
étape il ya la manière la plus simple et
la plus avancée la plus simple c'est que
vous demander ouvertement une personne
de dire voilà je vais chercher son signe
astrologique faut qu'elles soient au
courant parce que ça va impacter et
influencer ses réponses vous le dis moi
de qualité que tu penses avoir et deux
défauts que tu penses avoir et comme
elle sait que vous êtes en train de
chercher son signe astrologique
inconsciemment les réponses qui vont
devenir ces des choses qui sont liées à
ces signes si tant est qu'elles les
connaissent et donc elle va vous les
donner et après vous voyez dans quel cas
ça rentre le mieux sur les 12 signes
astrologiques la deuxième technique donc
qui est la plus compliquée parce que
c'est la plus déductif c'est de faire ce
travail là vous même d'essayer de voir
quels sont les défauts et qualités de
cette personne selon vous donc c'est
très subjectif et surtout si vous n'avez
pas vu la personne longtemps où
s'exprimaient longtemps et paris vous
ranger sa dans la case qu'il colle le
plus dans les défauts et qualités des
signes astrologiques alors c'est un peu
comme la vidéo
devinez un prénom la vraie méthode c'est
ça paraît rien de dire ça donc il faut
s'entraîner et se banane et mille fois
il peut être que parmi vous il y en a
qui vont arriver très vite avec ça et
peut-être y en a qui auront beaucoup
plus d'erreurs mais c'est la méthode en
tout cas la plus pure en termes de
mentalisme pour essayer de trouver le
signe astrologique de quelqu'un voilà
dans votre vie courante ou lorsque vous
aurez un rendez vous avec fruits selon
vos attentes vous rappelle que le lien
est dans la description merci à eux vous
pourrez essayer de trouver des signes
astrologiques de la personne et au pire
vous le trouvez pas il se passe quoi ça
vaut le coup d'essayer de le faire la
prochaine vidéo elle sortira lundi
prochain 18 heures cette vidéo avec
bernard werber qui va être un peu
passionnant passes manquées si vous
voulez me voir sur scène et après le
spectacle attention c'est les dernières
dates du spectacle je vous le dis je
vous le répète parce que après sur un
terrain vous dites quand est-ce que tu
passes à bordeaux la semaine dernière il
reste plus que neuf représentations et
après j'arrête définitivement ce
spectacle donc ce mois ci et le mois
prochain après c'est terminé je joue à
saint benoît à lyon à sa grégoire c'est
déjà complet à nantes à bourges à
boisseuil à besançon à la rochelle est
évidemment au zénith de paille même si
vous avez vu le spectacle venait de pas
réussi là aussi vous avez le lien dans
la description moi je m'appelle toujours
fabien olicard vous pouvez cliquer là
pour vous abonner toute manière si c'est
déjà fait elle leur fait passer nous
sommes les états bonne et là je vous
mets de cette vidéo vidéo sur l'hypnose
c'est plutôt l'hypnose thérapeutique et
une vidéo sur un concept de mentalisme
interactifs inédits c'est juste heures
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt ciao
mais au match là pis
vous êtes vous aujourd'hui